oui oui on a beau dire ce qu'on veut
malgré le bonheur qu'ils peuvent donner
moi je suis un supporteur de football
j'étais abonnée au parc des princes
durant de nombreuses années j'étais ravi
d'acheter des maillots de contribue
certainement à leur salaire mais ça
reste malgré tout indécent de gagner 100
mille deux cent mille trois cent mille
cinq cent mille euros peu importe pour
jouer à la baballe mais est ce qu'ils
les ont volé cet argent c'est vrai on
voit et je peux comprendre les français
qui disent regardez moi ce que je fais
je suis infirmière chez deux soignantes
je galère je me tue à la tâche ne gagne
pas beaucoup mais ce qu'ils ont volé cet
argent
non ils profitent du système ils ont le
droit de la voir si ce n'était pas
peut-être que c'est d'eux qu'il a
récupéré donc oui je pense qu'une
gagnent trop mais ce qu'il faudrait
baisser leur salaire
non parce qu'elle ne reviendrait pas
chez les autres personnes et faut pas
oublier que souvent il plaît énormément
d'impôts en dehors de ceux qui
bénéficient de l'évasion fiscale et donc
il contribue aussi à la solidarité donc
ça serait bien qu'on arrête un peu de
focaliser sur les footballeurs et qu'on
s'attaque à autre chose eric revel
en fait il ya une logique économique moi
je considère qu'ils sont extrêmement
trop payés trop bien payés en fait
quelle logique économique si ces gens
touchent autant d'argent c'est qu'en
réalité ils en font gagner beaucoup plus
à leur club à leurs agents et c'est donc
en fait le salaire qu'ils ont ils
répondent à cette logique économique là
maintenant la question que moi
j'aimerais qu'on se pose aussi c'est est
ce que quand on critique le salaire
exorbitant d'un grand patron qui créent
des emplois est ce qu'on a le même
regard sur un footballeur et la plupart
du temps considère qu'il n'est pas trop
payés donc en fait on l'absoute 7 de
cette dimension là on lui demande pas de
créer des emplois un footballeur on a un
avis sur saône non non mais ils ont un
avis sur le salaire patil entremets mais
en réalité on ne se pose jamais la ville
ancrée longtemps comparé bah bah si
parce qu'en france
en france la logique c'est de critiquer
précisément le grand patron des trousses
beaucoup d'argent et les joueurs de foot
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
et moi je suis étonné de ce que je vois
oui mais là le reste ans et non ailleurs
marc karim cette logique économique à
part karim par manger a pas eu plus ou
moins calmes mais la logique économique
c'est que ces gens rapportent beaucoup
plus d'argent qu'ils n'en coûte ans et
bernard que ce soit nb saint-bernard là
dans la la j'ai envie là on a vraiment
envie d'avoir ton avis et d'ambitieux
mais qu elle soit un dessin que ce soit
déraisonnable
on peut ainsi démarrer effectivement
abyss est évident que c'est il ya aucune
objet
dans mais ils ne le veulent pas et c'est
l'économie qui crée ça qui permet de les
payer
souvent on dit ouais les jours dans
l'oubli pourquoi vous n'êtes pas assez
payés mais désolé c'est le concret pas
une économie comme le football c'est
aussi simple que ça il gagne combien en
moyenne un moyen aujourd'hui j'avais
mille euros par mois en moyenne
c'est un entraîneur du top 14 chez veb
et de alors qu'armand alors alors qu en
ligue 1 voilà par exemple si on prend la
ligue 1
la moyenne et eric naulleau c'est quoi
de ce 3 200 milles moyenne même bassin
c'est plus de trois cents 300 400
millions pour les très gros salaires est
aussi bien le meilleur il ya 15000 1
alors dire dans quelle terre d'asile
sont touchés plus que des jeunes qui
sont émis chaque promotion d accord soit
ils jouent autant ces jeunes donc c'est
pour ça que oui c'est déraisonnable ça
fait peur 7e art selon dit elle on
compare alors aimer le football la
fédération française de rugby jeudi
aucune jalousie c'est comme ça il crée
une économie les droits télévision du
top 14 en rémission de 90 millions
d'euros
ils sont des milliards de dans le
football c'est incomparable mais encore
une fois personne ne leur met le
revolver sous la table il ya une
économie
il en profite bien à eux mais c'est
évident que c'est déraisonnable quand on
comparera sur un parcours bien sûr que
c'est très bon et c'est comme ça aux
gens les moyens aucune logique non au
moins dans un monde qui est celui de la
démesure de la perte de repères et de
sens
je dis qu'il faut poser quelques limites
je suis pour un salaire maximum mais pas
simplement pour le footballeur je dis
tranquillement moi un moment donné je
trouve un dessin qui est des gens même
s'ils rapportent à leur société
un ouvrier sur la chaîne de renault il
rapporte à renault que s'il est pas sur
la chaîne il est indispensable une
infirmière dans un hôpital elle n'est
pas d'un secteur marchand leur apporte à
la société qui est ce qu'elle est payée
en rapport de ce qu'elle rapporte à la
société de l'utilité de la fonction
qu'elle occupe la réponse est non
de farid et de marcher sur la tête quand
tu vois des footballeur document j'en
connais j'ai été footballeur j'étais un
centre de formation j'ai pas touché
cette somme là parce qu'à l'époque on
n'était pas cette folie là mais la
réalité ce quinté à 20 ans
la dga des gamins combien de temps tu
prends mbacké mbacké c'était un gamin et
mbappé mba pays tels 800000 euros par
mois ou 1 million par mois 2 sans
compter les contrats pu mais messi c29
ces mêmes de la dea
militer je vais vous dire c'est pas
qu'on me rapporte à elle qualifie ou au
qatari comme c'est pas ça le sujet le
sujet c est ce qu un moment donné on
peut peser des règles ce qui est
déraisonnable à ce qui est je dirais de
la folie pure
dans une société où tu as des gens qui
galèrent qui sont sur le bord du chemin
qui bossent et qui se lèvent le matin
qui est mort et que la valeur travail
soit beaucoup plus valorisée qu'au y
verrez qu'elle ne l'est et là on va te
dire maintenant l'équipe citadins de
malo ils remplissent des stades
oui en plus des stades et alors c'est
pas parce qu'un baiser stade qu'on ne
doit pas mettre de limites
je veux dire je comprends pas je
comprends pas le débat qui consiste à
dire ils rapportent qu'il faut qu'il
touche en fonction ce qu'ils rapportent
si on faisait ça les a mis devant tous
les salariés le salaire minimum serait
pas du tout il serait passé devant
économique c'est le tien mais encore une
fois je le dis y'a pas que je me disais
mais le footballeur ne sommes pas des
voleurs on leur donne les soudeurs et
refuser les mecs qui seraient des tarés
et dieu sait si c'est le système de
manière systémique
ça ne fonctionne pas mais je le dis même
pour les grands patrons qui toucherait
400000 euros par mois c'est endesa fait
derrière des pays où on a une échelle de
1 à 8 de salaires bas et c'est déjà pas
suffisament de toucher 8 fois que le
salarié de base oh ça ne sort pas avec
ça à la fin du mois si on veut répartir
un peu mieux les richesses qu'on nous le
fait croyez-moi dure au moins nos
malheureux eric naulleau non mais au
moment où un moment on essaie d'assurer
une retraite de 1000 euros à ceux qui
ont été au smic toute leur vie
évidemment les sommes qu'on évoque
peuvent parrainer d'accord après c'est
un système capitaliste et c'est même un
système ultra capitaliste le football
est peut-être le vraiment l'illustration
du capitalisme dans tout
outrancier bah oui mais entre le
capitalisme et tout rossi alors après
automne des règles qui nous attend et ça
compte ça concerne pas vraiment une
minorité de quelques dizaines de joueurs
mais le problème c'est qu'il va falloir
s'y habituer parce que ça fait que ne
vois que certains attendent c'est
important que dirige une dizaine de
jours de quoi non de quelques dizaines
de superstars qui touche bien sûr mais
qui touche coller un commun et non les
deux cent mille euros que tu disais
c'est pas une dizaine and on and on a
permis leur côté ont parlé de moyenne et
ça court ça concerne vraiment quand même
très peu de gens mais ça ne fait que
commencer
c'est un chasseur de frasne complètement
dérégulé
coût de joueurs qui sortent leur
mécontement dérégulé maintenant les
sommes des transferts ont complètement
explosé un joueur moyen est maintenant
vendu le prix qui était vendu le zidane
dans le temps bien sûr sans parler de
platini plat tout neuf c'était john
voilà donc ça ne fait il faut le dire
vite touché trois fois rien pour 2010
d'un monopoly
non parce que simplement et bernadette
tant que ça continuera à rapporter
on continuera à les payer de plus en
plus et les clubs s'arracheront ces
grands joueurs et seront prêts à trimer
c'est moi parce que c'est comme ça que
janot est tolérée eric et comment tu
veux façon sûre elle ne le met pas dans
un peu non décisions politiques avec toi
je suis je ne suis pas contre l'alors
leur salaire parce qu'effectivement
c'est proportionnel à ce qui génère
clairement il crée des emplois
contrairement à ce qu'on pense et puis
surtout on pense pas au fait que ce soit
des carrières courtes les carrières de
footballeurs sont extrêmement courts
continue à une blessure il ya dernière
derrière jacques leur carrière parfois
peuvent s'arrêter
donc en ça je trouve que c'est un senior
leurs commerciaux ils peuvent travailler
la reconversion est suffisamment
d'argent pour travailler là peut-être
effectivement et et encore une fois on
parle pas non plus je vais vous parler
du financement des retraites mais
certains payent leurs impôts en france
karim benzema par exemple paye ses
influences et il permet effectivement
aussi le financement des retraites
donc il faut pas non plus jeter la
pierre comme ça au football à et je
pense qu'on a quand même un sérieux
problème en france vis-à-vis des gens
qui gagnent de l'argent et qui créent de
la richesse donc ça pour rien que pour
ça je suis content alors justement tient
à quel gardien merci merci pour l aller
j'attends le bon guidon des riches et
des riches chinois ont fini à craquer a
dit ne pas dire à quel prix contre
intuitivement t'as vu je dis non car
j'ai parce que la question est celle est
footballeur pas certaines stars du
football veut dire oui non mais c'est
quand même karim c'est pas certaine ça
quand vous prenez en liga voilà en liga
mine de rien mais bien sûr trouvant à
bord des joueurs coûtent en moyenne elle
est beaucoup plus à 160 et 2005 en ligue
2 je répète qu'à 15 mio rés est-ce que
la moyenne ne veut rien dire
avait des personnes qui sont à 3
millions par mois une moyenne ne veut
plus rien dire
le mien qui arrive avec damian il ya un
club où sortait elle nous permet comme
du président de mener quand même une
équipe à bannu l'est pas parce que je
suis pas un garçon que j'ai pas loin de
parler de foot mais c'est beaucoup la
parole
premièrement c'est bien non alors donc à
mai avec lesquels on en a beaucoup parlé
de ça parce que c'est vrai que c'est une
cible facile de dire les salaires sont
tous là où et c'est vraiment je suis
d'accord avec toi sur la limitation en
ce que je suis d'accord avec ce que tu
as dit mais simplement je pense que dans
le système du football
ce qui est grave et la dérive qui est
grave c'est l'idée de faire oublier les
supporters des stades rentrer rendre
l'accès au stade beaucoup trop cher
aujourd'hui l'abonnement par exemple au
parc des princes est beaucoup trop cher
aujourd'hui le fait qu'on ait sort les
supporters production préoccupe bon bout
mais on te parle d'un programme de la
fifa non mais sérieux mais elle te mets
ma chérie pourquoi on parle de ça parce
que le droit moi je considère que par
exemple aujourd'hui il ya un problème
voilà il ya eu des modifications avec le
fait que canal+ a récupéré des droits
télé bravo mais est ce qu'ils sont en
vie un bing ciao milliards d'euros le
coût des droits télé qui tient ces faux
est riche maintenant quasiment pour
avoir le droit de voir le championnat
c'est à dire qu'avant c'était le young
et le golf qui était un sport de riche
maintenant si vous voulez voir et la
ligue 1 et la champions's league et
les autres bombes a maintenant il faut
être fois être fouettée me voilà donc
c'est un problème c'est à dire le sport
le foot est un sport alors les bacs de
le bousculer et je concédais cheveux
sous les chênes les droits les bruits de
transferts les plus le coût de transfert
pour moi est proposé entre regarder à
68% non à 32 p ça ne fait pas encore le
plateau et bien voilà une fois mariée
sur la tête